pop music is obviously a big part of all
of our lives really transformative do
you guys remember the first pop song
that you heard that you're like this is
it this is the best song of all time
like when you were a kid I mean I think
NSYNC was the thing that really got me
into pop music I loved and sync and then
in turn you know JT and then a whole
kind of Pharrell Timbaland period of
time I think it was sort of like yeah
the earliest of 2000s when I was you
know 15 16 yeah it was a very good time
for pop music so that's that's when I
sort of fell in love with it I think at
that time like little me I was listening
to like the Pussycat Dolls and those
like that was kind of my youth of like I
just felt like I could really like dance
like I loved that and my first concert I
went to was a Quin Stefani concert when
I was nine and then she dances to Quinn
Stefani so Geico commercial I'm sure how
much of that sort of youthful energy
that you know dance like nobody's
watching attitude did you bring to your
performance I felt like well I mean even
though there was a whole bunch of crew
watching that one the particular scene
where I do really dance in my bedroom it
was autumn and I who's the DP and I just
it was like a free-for-all
we'd blast music and I was in the in the
bedroom and I could just like I was so
sweaty and like dancing but I also was
funny like doing and I wanted to keep
doing it there's something about also
with the performances of the song when
you have a song that's even if it's
you're dancing you're singing like the
completion of it like you started it and
the finish it makes you like I need to
do this again it is again like the
adrenaline of that so it really felt it
was very free and and that wouldn't
wasn't like a choreographed sequence
some other things were choreographed in
in the in the movie but that I got to
just be myself so that's kind of what
I'm like I guess in my room is there a
particular
musical sequence musical performance in
the film that when you watch it back
it's the most satisfying to see I mean I
think the lat don't kill my vibe for me
is like I feel very proud of that one
because it was the most it was a song I
was most nervous about and the song I
knew the least I didn't because it was
chosen more towards the end and I also
but I knew that it had to be the best so
there was so much pressure on that
riding on it so I felt like violet like
everything's riding on this one
performance for violet and for El so
when I watch that one I get really
excited and it was that one isn't cut
with other scenes so it's like a more
I'm on stage and it's that scene instead
of like core of a montage music video
type asketh also the et sequence of the
I mean that's the dancing one like I'm
trying out I don't sing that song but
that sequence I love musical sequence
yeah
who are the big influences for you when
you were going into crafting the stage
persona of a violet I mean I really
wanted a violet to be an honest sort of
representation of a you know a young
woman in this world she has not she
doesn't smile all the time she's not
always nice she doesn't always do the
right thing but she's an incredibly
empathetic and human person I think we
can all relate to and I didn't really
want to make her like another pop star I
think she's a very unique and unique
character their own voice and I think al
did an amazing job of making a feel like
somebody who really so stands on their
own yeah yeah I feel like people can
especially with pop music people want to
give it like a bad like pop music
because I think also music lovers or
just people in general can really like
smell fakeness you know and I think it's
pop music is so manufactured that that's
what people don't like about it that's
like oh these people do they want to do
this album or did someone make them do
this album or way and I think the best
pop artists are the ones that are so
authentic to themselves and like even
like we like
ariana grande in this new album because
she we know that she wasn't told to put
that album out we know like these songs
are more personal like we like the
authenticity so with violet people like
her because she's authentic you know and
we like do a leap but kind of has that
same were also her story is a little bit
similar to violet not that we like took
it from her but still like that I don't
know her style a bit guys what is it
about Elle and this is gonna be like
compliment time so I'm not entirely sure
how you're gonna take this but what is
it about Elle that not only makes sort
of like perfect for violet but I mean
people really want to see her on on
screen what is it about that I don't
understand the Lasser I don't know why
people here's the thing in this movie
she she spoke polish she speaks of a
British accent she has to sing she has
to dance very complicated choreography
she's to milk goats there was like an
endless endless endless list of
requirements for this for this wall and
she was always ten minutes early she's a
consummate professional and on top of
all of that gives us insanely nuanced
performance which is one most like
remarkable for the poses when a young
actor I've ever seen and I don't think
I'm alone in feeling that has nothing to
me by the way like this was all her work
it's an amazing it's an amazing thing I
think she just has a very unique talent
I think it's just kind of a god-given
god-given thing but the hard work part
is not god-given and that was really
remarkable exceptional as well she's
gonna sort of out outlive all of us what
would you like to see her come onboard
handmaids for example and work with her
and that and that yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're also excited about a new
Maleficent movie coming up is anything
you tell us about we're about where this
story is going next but I'm really used
they've moved the date up so I'm so
excited it's coming out this year
there's so much sooner than people
thought so
I haven't even I haven't seen it so but
I can't I can't wait with the cast is
like exceptional and it's also it's just
more that you know mother-daughter
relationship between or
and Maleficent any goat milking no no I
had to think about it though